QUOTE, LEADER OF PEACE.
THIS COMES AS DEFENSE SECRETARY
MEETS IN BRUSSELS TO DISCUSS THE
ATROCITIES HAPPENING IN UKRAINE.
JOINING ME NOW IS NATO SECRETARY
GENERAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
WE JUST HEARD ANOTHER POWERFUL
SPEECH FROM PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
TO THE U.S. CONGRESS.
I'LL GET INTO HIS SPECIFIC ASKS
IN A MOMENT, BUT I WANT TO BEGIN
WITH THE RATHER SHARP REBUKE
THAT HE DIRECTED AT INSTITUTIONS
MEANT TO PREVENT WAR AND OF
COURSE THAT WOULD INCLUDE NATO.
HE SAID THEY DON'T WORK AND
CALLED FOR NEW ONES THAT HAVE
QUOTE, THE STRENGTH TO PROVIDE
WHATEVER IS NECESSARY TO SAVE
THE WORLD.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> I FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
DESPERATION EXPRESSED BY
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY AND THAT'S
ALSO THE REASON WHY OUR NATO
ALLIES PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORT TO UKRAINE AND MINISTERS
AT THE MEETING IN BRUSSELS TODAY
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
MILITARY SUPPORT AS ALLIES DO.
AND THE U.S. IS LEADING THOSE
EFFORTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO NATO, NATO'S
CORE RESPONSIBILITY AND MAIN
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PROTECT 1
BILLION PEOPLE LIVING IN 30 NATO
COUNTRIES.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT FOR
70 YEARS AND HAVE STEPPED UP OUR
PRESENCE TO REMOVE ANY ROOM FOR
MISCALCULATION OR
MISUNDERSTANDING IN MOSCOW ABOUT
OUR WITNESS TO PREVENT ANY
ATTACK ON ANY NATO COUNTRY AND
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN UKRAINE
NOW.
>> BUT PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS
SAYING THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO PREVENT
AND STOP A THREE-WEEK WAR THAT
HAS KILLED THOUSANDS OF HIS
CITIZENS.
>> WE HAVE DO SO FOR MORE THAN
70 YEARS AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
THAT.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE
REENFORCE OUR COLLECTIVE
DEFENSE.
ESPECIALLY IN THE EASTERN PART
OF THE ALLIANCE.
UKRAINE IS NOT A NATO MEMBER,
BUT UKRAINE IS A HIGHLY VALUED
PARTNER AND NATO ALLIES HAVE
TRAINED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
UKRAINIAN TROOPS FOR MANY YEARS.
WE HAVE OVER MANY, MANY YEARS
PROVIDED ESSENTIAL EQUIPMENT TO
UKRAINE AND ALLIES AND ARE
PROVIDING EVEN MORE SUPPORT
INCLUDING WITH AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS AND OTHER ADVANCED
WEAPON SYSTEMS TO HELP THEM TO
FIGHT THE INVADING RUSSIAN
FORCES.
>> THERE'S ONE THING WE'VE
LEARNED OUT OF THIS IS THAT
UKRAINE IS DEFINITELY NOT A NATO
MEMBER AND IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE
HEARD OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGING IT WON'T BE ONE
ANYTIME SOON.
TO PUT A BUTTON ON THIS, WANTING
TO REITERATE HIS POINT THAT IF
NATO WASN'T DOING ENOUGH TO
PREVENT RUSSIA'S INVASION INTO
UKRAINE, THAT NATO COUNTRIES
COULD BE NEXT.
>> BUT THAT'S EXACTLY WHY WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED THE BIGGEST
PORTION OF COLLECTIVE DEFENSE
SINCE THE COLD WAR.
WE NOW HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF NATO TROOPS ON
HEIGHTENED ALERT ACROSS THE
ALLIANCE.
WE HAVE 100,000 U.S. TROOPS IN
EUROPE AND IT HAS INCREASED
SEVERAL THOUSAND JUST IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS.
WE HAVE MORE THAN 40,000 TROOPS
ON THE DIRECT NATO COMMAND
SUPPORTED BY SIGNIFICANT AIR AND
NAVAL CAPABILITIES.
SO THIS IS WHAT TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO ATTACK ON ANY
NATO ALLY COUNTRIES.
OF COURSE, NATO HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE AS NATO ALLIES DO, BUT
ALSO HAVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
PREVENT THIS CONFLICT FROM
ESCALATING BEYOND UKRAINE
BECAUSE THE SUFFERING, THE
DEATH, THE DESTRUCTION WE SEE
NOW IN UKRAINE CAN BECOME WORSE
IF THIS ESCALATES TO FULL FLEDGE
WAR BETWEEN NATO AND RUSSIA IN
EUROPE.
>> AND ONE WAY THAT NATO
MEMBERS, INCLUDING PRESIDENT
BIDEN, VIEW A POSSIBLE
ESCALATION OF THIS WAR THAT
COULD INCLUDE POSSIBLY BRINGING
THE FIGHT TO A NATO AND ITS
BORDERS AND BEYOND THAT IS TO
INSTILL NOW AND IMPOSE A NO FLY
ZONE.
THAT SEEMS TO BE A NONSTARTER
EVEN THOUGH PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
CONTINUES TO ASK FOR THAT.
OTHER THAN THAT, THERE IS OTHER
AID THAT IS HEADED NOW TO
UKRAINE.
OTHER ASKS, HE'S ASKING FOR IN
ADDITION TO DEFENSE SYSTEMS,
RIGHT, IS AIRPLANES.
OUR AIRPLANES.
WILL THAT BE PART OF THE PACKAGE
NOW?
>> NATO ALLIES ARE PROVIDING
MORE AND MORE MILITARY SUPPORT
TO EQUIP THEM TO UKRAINE
INCLUDING ADVANCED SYSTEMS ALSO
TO PROTECT THEM IN THE AIR.
AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS, DRONES, AND
OTHER MEANS TO ALSO DEAL WITH
THE THREATS THEY'RE FACED WITH
IN THE AIR SPACE OR IN THE AIR.
SO I THINK FOR OPERATIONAL
REASONS, WE SHOULD BE A BIT
CAREFUL GOING INTO EVERY
SPECIFIC TYPE OF WEAPONS SYSTEM
WE ARE DELIVERING.
BUT THE MESSAGE FROM TODAY IS
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO STEP UP
TO PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT.
I WELCOME THE ANNOUNCEMENT FROM
THE UNITED STATES AND OTHER
ALLIES TO PROVIDE MORE FUNDING
FOR MILITARY ASSISTANCE AND OF
COURSE IT'S FIRST AND FOREMOST A
COURAGE OF THE UKRAINIAN ARMED
FORCES THAT'S STOPPED AND HOLD
BACK THE RUSSIAN INVASION, BUT
THE TRAINING AND THE SUPPORT OF
NATO ALLIES CONTINUE TO DIVERT
MILITARY EQUIPMENT HAS OF COURSE
BEEN ESSENTIAL IN ENABLING THEM
TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST THE
INVADING RUSSIAN FORCES.
>> BUT YOU CAN'T CONFIRM NOW, I
UNDERSTAND THE SENSITIVITY HERE,
BUT YOU CAN'T CONFIRM NOW THAT
PLANES, SPECIFICALLY THE MIG
29s, WILL BE PART OF THIS
PACKAGE?
>> I CANNOT GO INTO THE
SPECIFIC.
THE ONLY THING I CAN SAY IS THAT
NATO ALLIES ARE PROVIDING ALSO
SYSTEMS THAT CAN HELP THEM
PROTECT AGAINST AIR ATTACKS, AIR
AND MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEMS
INCLUDING ADVANCED SYSTEMS,
WHICH ACTUALLY HELP THEM TO
SHOOT DOWN PLANES AND MISSILES
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE
ALSO SEE THE VALUE OF THIS
MILITARY SUPPORT PROVIDED
AMONGST MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
>> U.S. ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
HAVE CONFIRMED THIS MORNING THAT
JAKE SULLIVAN SPOKE TODAY WITH
HIS RUSSIAN COUNTERPART.
THAT WOULD BE THE FIRST HIGH
LEVEL CONTACT SINCE THIS
INVASION BEGAN.
IT COMES AS NEW CNN REPORTING
REVEALS THAT NATO HAS ALSO TRIED
TO CONNECT WITH RUSSIA AND HAS
THUS FAR BEING UNSUCCESSFUL.
DOES THAT SOUND TO YOU LIKE
RUSSIA IS TRYING TO CUT NATO OUT
OF ANY COMMUNICATION AT THIS
POINT?
>> WELL, OUR COMMANDERS, THEY
HAVE THE LINES FOR
COMMUNICATIONS AND IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
WHATEVER POSSIBLE TO PREVENT ANY
INCIDENTS OR ACCIDENTS AND IF
THEY HAPPEN, TO ENSURE THAT THEY
DON'T SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL
BECAUSE WITH HEIGHTENED
TENSIONS, MORE MILITARY CLOSE TO
THE BORDERS, WE SAW THE ATTACK
ON THE TRAINING CENTER CLOSE TO
THE POLISH BORDER A FEW DAYS
AGO.
OF COURSE, THE RISK FOR
ACCIDENTS HAS INCREASED AND
THEREFORE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
COMMANDERS HAVE THE NECESSARY
LINES OF COMMUNICATION.
WE USE THEM IF NECESSARY.
>> THE LINES ARE OPEN, BUT HAVE
THE RUSSIA